Kim Kardashian is seemingly beefs up
security as sister Courtney rocks out
and Kylie Jenner cooks dinner in an
unusual outfit if this was any man that
we were with we would be pissed plus a
dramatic first look at Sunday's Keeping
Up with the Kardashians Kim was snapped
at hubby Kanye West's third at Los
Angeles concert Thursday night
surrounded by security and going a
little incognito in a black baseball cap
the star still has not returned to
social media since the Paris robbery
incident earlier this month her sisters
of course have Kourtney was at Kanye's
show to rocking out in the crowd sharing
it all on a snapchat majority baby for
making lasagna and youngest sis Kylie
Jenner was at home making dinner in her
underwear he hasn't spoken to her in
days why are you leave a pregnant I
don't give up and in this sneak peek at
this week's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Khloe is calling out Rob
foregoing a radio a silent on blac Chyna
that's crazy how he's acting that's
really up rob is going to be a dad and
he has a family to answer to so I feel
like now more than ever Rob can't handle
things the way he once did
you